RAAAAAAGH!
Widescreeeeen!
Look at this. NYAAAAAAAGH!
(intro music)
This video is composed of fifty jokes from Nerdfighters like you.
Two drums and a cymbal walk off a cliff.
Badum tssss!
(singing) Billy was a chemist's son, but now he is no more,
(singing) what he thought was H2O was H2SO4, HEY!
There are two muffins in an oven. One says,
(Muffin Hank 1) "Man, it is hot in here!"
And the other one says,
(Muffin Hank 2) "HOLY CRAP, a talking muffin!"
A child comes up to his dad and asks,
(Young Hank) "Daddy, is God a man or a woman?"
(Dad Hank) "God is both."
(Young Hank) "Is God black or white?"
(Young Hank) "Is God Michael Jackson?"
What's the difference between Neil Armstrong and Michael Jackson?
Neil Armstrong walked on the moon,
And Michael Jackson is F***ING CRAZY!
Why do ducks have webbed feet?
To stomp out fires.
Why do elephants have flat feet?
To stomp out the burning ducks.
(Hank 1) "How do you kill an elephant?"
(Hank 2) "Whuuu...?"
(Hank 1) "With an elephant gun."
(Hank 1) "How do you kill a blue elephant?"
(Hank 2) "With an elephant gun?"
(Hank 1) "With a blue elephant gun."
(Hank 1) "How do you kill a red elephant?"
(Hank 2) "Uhhh... With a red elephant gun?"
(Hank 1) "No, you choke it until it's blue, then you shoot it with a blue elephant gun."
(Hank 1) "How do you kill a purple elephant?"
(Hank 2) "You choke it until it's blue, and then you shoot it with a blue elephant gun."
(Hank 1) "Oh my g- There is no such thing as a purple elephant."
Why is six so afraid of seven?
Uh, because seven ate nine.
What's brown and sticky?
A stick.
What do Christmas and a cat in the desert have in common?
Sandy Claws.
Does Snoop Dogg ever need an umbrella?
Fo' drizzle!
There are 10 types of people in the world.
Those who know binary and those who don't.
(Hank 1) "Man, it smells like updog in here!'
(Hank 2) "What's updog?"
(Hank 1) Nothing, what about you?
The square root of negative one and pi are having an argument.
After much discussion, the square root of negative one shouts at pi,
"Please! Would you just be rational?!
Pi responds,
(sighs) "Get real!"
How much did the pirate pay to get his ears pierced?
A buck-an-ear.
What did the pirate say when he got a steering wheel stuck down his pants?
(Pirate Hank) "Arr, it's drivin' me nuts!"
A kid dressed as a pirate for Halloween knocks on his neighbor's door.
(Neighbor Hank) "Oh, aren't you a cute little pirate, but where are your buccaneers?"
(Kid Hank) "Under my buckin' hat!"
So there's this pirate and he's walking around, and he's wearing a paper towel for a hat.
And so I ask him,
"What's with the paper towel?"
(Pirate Hank) "Arr, I got a bounty on me head."
Why couldn't the little pirate go see the movie?
Because it had too much booty. And it was rated ARRR!
Why does it take pirates so long to learn the alphabet?
'Cause they could spend years at C!
Why don't dinosaurs talk?
Because they're DEAD!
How do you make a handkerchief dance?
You put a little boogie in it.
How to avoid bad knock-knock jokes:
Knock knock!
Uh- Come in!
What do politicians and sperm have in common?
About one in every 500 or 600 million have a chance of becoming a human.
A grasshopper walks into a bar.
The bartender says,
"Hey, we got a drink named after you!
The grasshopper says,
"Uh, you got a drink named Larry?
One atom says to the other atom,
(Atom Hank 1) "HOLY CRAP, I just lost an electron!"
(Atom Hank 2) "Are you sure?"
(Atom Hank 1) "Yes! I'm positive!"
Why did the monkey fall out of the tree?
Because it was DEAD!
But why did the second monkey fall out of the tree?
Because it was stapled to the first monkey!
But why did the third monkey fall out of the tree?
P-peer pressure.
I wish to die peacefully in my sleep, like my grandfather.
Not panicking. Like his passengers.
Did you hear about the guy who got the entire left half of his body cut off?
Yeah, but he's all right now.
What is the relationship between a pumpkin's circumference and its radius?
Pumpkin pi.
Why don't oysters give to charity?
Well, because they're shellfish.
What are the two dirtiest animals in the farmyard?
(singing) Brown chicken brown cow!
(I don't believe I just did that.)
Where does the king keep his armies?
In his sleevies!
How many surrealists does it take to change a lightbulb?
...Fish.
How many psychologists does it take to change a lightbulb?
Just one, but the lightbulb has to want to change.
What did the bear say to the other bear when they finished eating the clown?
"Did he taste funny to you?"
What do you get when you mix an agnostic, a dyslexic, and an insomniac?
A dude who sits up all night wondering whether there is a dog.
What do you call a female sex change?
An addadictomy.
What do you call a male sex change?
A lopatoffomy.
Two fish are in a tank. One fish says to the other fish,
"Do you know how to drive this thing?"
What kind of cheese just isn't yours?
Nacho cheese!
Why was the math book so sad?
It had a lot of problems.
What's the difference between a writer and a park bench?
A park bench can support a family.
John, just kidding, That was fifty jokes, I'll see you later!
Leave your favorite jokes in the comments, I kind of want to make another one of these.